hey you guys how's it going it's Justine
and today we are doing a what's on my
iPhone 10 video these videos are always
so highly requested and so crazy because
a lot of the times I start completely
fresh when I get a new phone and the
iPhone 10 is no exception I also started
fresh from I got the iPhone 8 and I
thought for sure that I was gonna just
port everything over to the new ones and
I decided no I'm gonna start fresh on my
iPhone 10 let's do this
and it usually takes me a good two weeks
which it's been a little bit over two
weeks now that have had the iPhone 10 to
really get back into the flow figure out
what apps I need and you definitely
figure out very very quickly what apps
you cannot live without when you don't
have any apps at all so starting on my
first page these are not quite in any
particular order like I used to have
let's see pays to have this over here I
like to have my maps I don't really use
my phone that often but I'll put that
one back over there so things aren't
exactly the way that I used to have them
but this is sort of my work in progress
this is what I cannot live without
basically I should title it back what
apps can I not live without No clickbait
hello only clickbait if it's not true to
starting off here from the top I've got
my calendar I've got my Apple maps and
Google Maps and I tend to only use Apple
maps when I'm in the car and I have it
connected to car play because it
integrates very well with my car then if
I'm wearing my watch it alerts me when I
need to turn so a lot of times they'll
opt to use that when I'm driving as
opposed to Google Maps but I do feel
like if I need to get somewhere and I
want to make sure that there's a traffic
or this or that I do feel like Google is
much more reliable still to this day but
Apple Maps integrates with my car and my
body so it's it's a tough choice anyway
moving on o'clock we've got the phone
we've got the Notes app which I use a
lot I use it for everything I use it for
making lists things that I need to buy
video ideas it's probably my number one
most used app next to messages next is
the App Store then Instagram Twitter
snapchat HQ trivia if you guys haven't
been playing HP trivia it is the most
fun game I've been talking about a
non-stop it's not sponsored this is just
honest-to-goodness excitement for a fun
game basically twice a day there is live
trivia you play you can win real money
if you'd like and you have it already
sign up using my little code right there
so that I can get some free lives yes I
need the lives then if you miss a
question it's almost like you didn't
actually miss it because they gave you a
life but you can only use one life per
game
ah the struggle I am so bad at trivia
it's unbelievable next up we have
Facebook and then Amazon and then Amazon
Prime now which allows you to get
deliveries almost within an hour or two
Apple TV remote YouTube and then YouTube
studio which is a studio app for
creators it basically lets you have more
features you can edit thumbnails you can
do stuff that creators need to to who
there's more in-depth analytics you get
the point
settings Starbucks very important right
next to post mates and if I didn't have
Cole's mates I probably would be very
hungry all the time or I would have to
learn to cook and clearly we know how
cooking goes for me and down the bottom
I have kind of like my most used things
which no matter what page I'm on I like
to have them easily accessible I've got
my messages my email which clearly I
need to check that Safari and my camera
handle the next page we have well it
says it's weather but this is basically
I need to change that actually let's
change that too I'm gonna rename it to
stuff this is basically all of the Apple
stuff that I didn't really wanna
necessarily delete but I don't really
ever look at weather news stocks
reminders iTunes Store iBooks home
health kits wallet photos FaceTime
podcast compass find iPhone find friends
tips a voice memo con I can probably
delete the tips the files app keynote
iMovie watch oh there's a watch update I
better get on that calculator pages
music and TV no I do use a lot of these
apps but a lot of times when I'm looking
for something I just kind of swipe down
and search for it so if I'm looking for
pages I don't really want to have it on
my home screen but I can find it easily
by going into the folder or searching
coinbase if you guys are a bit coin or
aetherium or virtual currency who
purchasers owners that's probably my
favorite cube this looks like a very fun
game but it's more a game of life it's a
period tracker sorry guys
ladies you might want to check it out
next we have Netflix their facebook
Messenger I clearly don't really use
that very often because I could
messages uber venmo Sonos Dropbox the
Apple Store Phillips hue which I love
that's what I use to control my lights
DJ I go for that's what I use to fly my
drone the activity tracker for my Apple
watch and my phone PayPal
Spotify clips I love the new clips act
like you can push yourself and it's kind
of struggling because it uses depth to
sense to remove the background and since
I'm pretty close to this wall actually
it's doing pretty good job let's see
what else we've got metropolis we've got
this riverfront this is my favorite it's
the Millennium Falcon so you can like
look around and see stuff that's around
you Oh a mega destroyer what we look at
this oh my god what else is there ah
sketchbook 8-bit Teegarden these are
really cool new clips update is pretty
great I just wished that they would make
it so that you can film vertical instead
of making everything square because that
really messes up when I'm gonna save
things to Instagram and like I can't put
this in my story it's a square what are
you thinking tumblr saucy if guys don't
know what saucy is you guys may not be
old enough but it is an alcohol delivery
service so yeah it's kind of like post
mates but for alcohol and last but not
least I have my games folder I haven't
really downloaded many games with teaser
basically my go choose I never made a
video a long time ago making this cake
from cookie Jam but I'm currently
working on something else very fun also
from that game so spoiler alert Jedi
challenges I did in a box scene with my
friend Alex if you want to watch that
video I'll put a link in the description
and an annotation somewhere here it's
kind of like a really insane AR game
where you can be a Jedi and you just use
your phone you put it into the headset
you have a lightsaber and man it's just
the best
next I have goat simulator which I just
started playing I kind of want to do
some gameplay of it so I stopped playing
so that I can sort of go through and you
guys can see my actual genuine
excitement and surprise from playing it
because I opened it up I was like what
is this this is the best thing that I've
ever seen in my entire life
I also have best fiends and best fiends
forever because obviously another game
that I'm obsessed with this is the
destiny to companion app so if you guys
play destiny at all that's something
that you can use to alert your clan
that you're gonna be going and getting
ready for the raid I still haven't
raided yet I just really need to take
like a week off from real life and just
sit and play destiny prestige and call
of duty and finish Mario Odyssey I think
that'll probably be what I do during
Thanksgiving and Christmas so maybe then
I can catch up on games well I guess
that's it let me know if you guys think
that there's any other apps that I'm
missing I did have a few AR apps there
was it was that Dragon app it's like
this little dragon friend but I didn't
download it on my new phone yet there's
a bunch of other AR apps that I do want
to check out I know I keep talking about
wanting to try AR a if you have any
other recommendations of ones that you
guys like or some things that you've
been playing that you think that I would
also enjoy feel free to leave those in
the comments below and let me know if
there's any other apps that you think
that I'm missing I feel like there's so
many apps that I can just get lost in
the App Store downloading and buying
things so if you'd like to help guide my
purchases or free games let me know in
the comments below and let me know what
your favorite app is is there an app
that is your favorite of all time
whether it's an iPhone or an Android
feel like probably the camera and
messages app if everything else went
away I could survive with just those two
things well thank you guys for watching
I will see you in my next video if you
haven't already don't forget to
subscribe so you'll see the next one be
sure to turn the alerts on because I
feel like that's the only way that
people see videos now that's a little
bell so you can click that on my channel
and on all of your other favorite
creators channels as well okay I'm gonna
go see you later
[Music]
[Applause]